there's no two ways about it meeting
darren aronofsky completely changed my
life you know I mean without having met
him the reality is that i probably
wouldn't have the career because not
because i can't do to me but just
getting that opportunity to work with
somebody who somebody who has that drive
and wants things and you know and you
can collaborate with them and but you
know you make a like mind that that you
work together you end up with something
you never would have ever expected to
get to you know and how so when you're
working with him or while the directors
how early do you like to get involved
well my preferred thing is to get
involved as soon as possible i mean with
with that it's differently darren
because I've you know we're just doing
know and I wish I think I six or seven
film together but I read the script of
that like nearly ten years ago Wow an
early version of that script you know I
mean it has several advantages which are
obvious I mean one of them is that
you've got more time and so you also
have more time to explore possibly wrong
avenues and and backtrack and and try
something else the one problem with it
is that often scheduled film schedules
slide and they tend to expand as more
editing is deemed necessary on a movie
one of the frustrating things for me
about working in film was getting
everything so late and feeling very
little involvement with the project and
its really really hard to be
passionately involved in something where
they're going it's done it's finished
you've got two days get it out there one
of the amazing things I think that's
happening more and more in the games
industry is that the composer is
integrated into that process much
earlier on when you finally get it a lot
more you know get a lock picture but a
fine cut of a picture that you can
actually start to score the time isn't
always too short you know you're always
pushed and particularly now because the
composer who traditionally had a little
window whilst the sound
who were building their tracks in which
the picture could never change there was
a kind of a thing where the picture then
became the property of the sound crew
and the composer and it kind of would
grow in the dark you know as they did
their work right well now that doesn't
happen because the cutting room will
still be looking at it and producers
will still be looking at the film the
whole time if you can get any clues or
get going or get in early I think it's
very very helpful so so let's say you're
on a film for four months i mean i've
been on Noah for like a year now you
know which is perhaps a little long but
you're writing every day you quite
strict about you out well I i am and i'm
not i mean it over that length of time
it's sort of difficult to be i find
consistent if you like you I think this
natural breaks you need to take you know
just for perspective just to not be so
tired maybe to you know go and see some
other movies listen to some other music
and and find some fresh impetus if you
like and do you tend to work solo would
you bring another players to help you
with certain ideas I work very much
alone mostly but I just did something
last week where I brought in a few
players to play a couple of q's just to
kind of sell it a little bit you know
because there is a couple of like
melodies or lead lines or something that
you know kind of need to just speak a
little bit compared to what a sample
yeah even if you've got the best string
or libraries in the world you know they
still you know still what they are but
to get a couple of players in just to
sort of do you know a couple of things
can really just add a little bit of a
proper emotion I suppose you know so
that's sort of that's a good thing to do
but I'm not some at you know it's it's
me in a darkened room a lot of now you
know mostly at work yes on a keyboard
connected to a couple of computers and
it's very rare that I sit at the piano
with a piece of paper although I filled
up I don't know how many notebooks in my
old days of counterpoints
with paper and pencil but no nowadays
it's I find it much faster to go
straighten the computer do you use that
therefore just walk a straight something
fully before taking it yes exactly I
would do demos or more cups that are as
detail and as realized as possible one
of the things that it's made so much
easier is syncing to picture in the old
days you had to have a click track book
which told you where you would be in the
score is like a sort of mathematical
table with lots of tempos in the book
and you and you'd find the temper that
you wanted to play out and they would
tell you which where each be would fall
and you could check it against the cue
sheet of the film sounds like a
nightmare yeah whatever it's better
spent more time writing out the sink
points I did writing the music very
often well now you don't have to do any
of that because you can just lock it up
and you can just look and what do you
play yourself guitar and a little bit of
piano I wouldn't play it in front of
anybody because I'm terrible like Les
Dawson really good I mean really my main
instrument is the computer really
because you know I say it's like having
a big tape recorder and you know you put
an idea on this one part on this one
track if you like and then you can start
adding stuff to it you know and you
build it up that way and so I'm very
much a component of the modern era in
that respect I think you know but I then
I do love then listening it come to life
when we volks traded it and they perform
it you know when I go into the studio
although there are usually enormous time
constraints and pressures on the day I
do like to be surprised with the dear
Esther score I had the strings scored so
those are really nice vibrato quite a
Hollywood sound but because the game is
set on a hybrid in Ireland one of the
players just said I don't know this
sounds right it just sounds so lush and
he said could we try a take with no
vibrato so kind of almost early music
Fargo kind
it's kind of carter burwell sound and it
just was like that's the right thing and
I think if you set up an atmosphere
where you're very controlling and very
constraining they don't feel they can
have that input and actually it's what
makes the sound absolutely it is the
deer after sound I feel sometimes and
this isn't a slight on anybody but there
are a lot of jobbing composes if you
like who do go Ben don't Ben doesn't beg
done and that's great that's that's
their process and that's perfectly fine
but for me it's like I kind of want
every every one of them to be personal
and and have me and if you like and
those things for me take time you know
so I'm always happy to have as much time
on a project as I can you know and the
other thing is the writ I mean the acid
it is a difficult job at times it is
frustrating and just sort of pressure
and tension at the end of the day you're
writing music I mean how bad can it be
you know me
you